Reggie Miller NBA on TNT analyst
hall-of-famer he'll be on the call
Thursday night he's got the Rockets at
the sun's 10:30 Eastern on TNT reg good
morning how are you I am great how are
you gentlemen doing this morning well
everybody's pretty good except for
Fritzi because somehow he took it
personally that the Knicks blew a 23
point lead last night and he wants
answers here reg he can't believe that
the Knicks would allow the Cavs to come
back now we come back but I believe they
were up that amount like late in the
third as well to lose that game look I
was watching it I was getting ready to
turn it off and I was getting ready to
formulate my ideas that I knew you're
gonna say was a loser's after that
blowout and then it went down from 23 to
18 then 18 to 16 11 I was like wait a
minute and then next thing you know the
reason were raining down Kyle Korver was
looking like Reggie Miller out there
well beyond the arc whoa is gonna
remember Kyle Korver great shooter I can
see a top-10 of all time is it something
that high I would say so yes I would say
Kyle Korver a top-ten shooter only
player shooter right yeah yeah you would
definitely be a tough test yeah he's not
in for defense or passing no no straight
shooting yeah what's the most shots you
missed in a row and a shooter keep
shooting but at some point doubt starts
to creep in I'm guessing that's are you
talking about personally or just in
general for me free cuz I never thought
that never you never thought oh okay
okay I put too much time in the lab to
know that if I missed ten in a row I
could easily make my next two in a row
that's 50% okay I'm headed to the
holiday Korver said he was asking misses
first five and then he was asked about
you know do you think about not shooting
because she can't make him if you don't
shoot him
that's right shooter shoot I mean that's
our mentality we're like release
pictures would come in just give us the
ball and leave us alone will
we'll finish the game and that's the
mentality you got to have alright so the
Knicks last night were playing really
well and then LeBron has this little run
in there with Kanter loved it did it
feel like he was trying to do something
I don't know it don't like it was a
little more calculated that uh could be
I mean remember there was the shelf with
the point guard Katrina
was ranked the tank and then Kanter came
over and took us back what he should but
look I manufactured and came up with
things in my head in the garden Jordan
did the same thing you've got to kind of
manufacture your own little scenarios
out there to kind of get you going and
it looked like LeBron did that and it
worked you know we been asking what's
been wrong with the Cavaliers for the
last couple weeks this is a game on that
stage that can turn around a season
again I still think they're the
favorites to win the East but it's games
like this that band of brothers and
teens together and you kind of saw that
on full display yesterday from the bench
reaction to Isiah Thomas and Jeff green
and it was just great to watch a team
really come together now let's see if
they can carry that momentum the rest of
this first half and get it going but
it's games like that that could kind of
turn your season around you got the
Rockets on Thursday night at the Suns
the game has become really easy for
James Harden I mean it is Reggie I know
everybody thinks the Greek freak is the
MVP in waiting to meet it's it's James
Harden this is James Harden's award this
year I agree right now it's probably
those are the two leaders the Greek
freaking and the bearded one the big
question is going to be when crispy
aspect because right now the primary
ball handling duties and the
facilitating has all come from James
Harden he's been able to score he's been
able to set up all those guys well now
you add another floor general like Chris
Paul and a guy that to be successful
frankly needs the ball in his hand to me
that's what I want to see Mike D'Antoni
has not really had to deal with about
this season because of the inn
to cp3 but I agree 100 if the award was
handed out three weeks into the season
which it's not yeah I would probably go
with James Harden 1a and javis Yanis
opted to coop Oh probably 1b why is
hardened making it look easy I think the
game has slowed down for him let's also
say this the guys around him have gotten
much better from Ryan Anderson I know
they you know they changed up Beverly
Gordon now is inserted into the starting
lineup he was he is the reigning Sixth
Man of the Year so he's back to just
starting so guys around him have gotten
better but hey this is the guys he
continually works on his game during the
summer James Harden has never taken the
summer off he's always playing in the
drew league or he's you know flying
across country and playing in New York
the guy stays in the lab working on his
craft how surprised were you that Magic
Johnson told Mike and Mike that they're
not trying to alter Alonzo ball Shawn
I'm not surprised at all I mean that's
really what kind of got him to the
league was that shot in the trying to do
that i I mean I anyone who's made it to
the professional rings and you're gonna
try to alter their shot that's why I was
kind of head scratching when we were
talking about mark elf old class last
week yeah you're here for a reason
this is what got you here that shot got
him to the NBA coming from UCLA so no I
agree with magic now you just got to
work on it yeah but how do you what do
you work on I think repetition it's more
key for him you know it really looks
like that's you know we talked about the
rookie wall usually coming right before
the all-star break and a little bit
after to me doesn't look like he has a
lot of leg strength and because he
shoots it on the left side it starts on
the left side and kind of ends like a
above his head it takes a lot to get up
there so I think it looks like he has
dead legs and so to me it would be all
about repetition with
she just Alvin gotta shoot a thousand
and to build up those legs that's
interesting cuz I he doesn't really put
his legs in his shot that much oh he
does really yeah do you think it's all
arm it feels like that it feels like
it's all it's more upper-body than it is
legs well it's a unique shot I
personally I personally would not change
it because that's who you are that's
what made you successful and that's how
you became the second pick in the draft
now it's all about mechanics and and
really trusting your shot I don't think
you really trust a shot yes you can you
can see and you know this as a scorer he
seems hesitant almost like yeah
don't leave me open because then I got
it and you've been around guys like that
they're like damn don't throw me the
ball if I'm open I don't want to take
this shot because I don't want to miss
it
and and he knows he's being critiqued in
a variety of ways especially with that
shot now and I think he even came out
and said it's all in my head
so already three weeks into the season
he's talking about mentally the game
being somewhat difficult for him with
his shooting but I'm not gonna get too
high too low on long football because
we're only three weeks in and you know
what the youngest player to have a
triple-double just a couple games ago
they want a big game on the road last
night in Phoenix you know so it'll come
slowly but it will come it's not gonna
be like it was for Summer League where
everyone was saying that he's the second
coming or Jason Kidd but it slowly but
surely will come most shots missed in a
game you were 9 for 27 against the
Hornets in 1991 whoa how could you miss
18 shots reg
wow did we win the game or lose you had
25 points 8 rebounds and 6 assists
terrible night for me that's terrible
for a shooter because remember I only
ever vision my career maybe 13 or 14
shots a game so for me to take 27 sides
in a game that is Wow
why did you not go why did you guys lost
by two you know it no but I bring it up
because yes greatest shooters you were
and are you everybody has these nights
and I'm just I'm it's an example that
you had one bad night in your entire
career and it was minus twenty seven
it's not good neither 27 is that good
why didn't you shoot more I wanted to be
efficient I wanted to be an efficient
scorer we you know look we had ritzmitz
Mark Jackson we had my Davis boy so I
didn't need to take 20-plus shots yeah
you know to be great so if I can make
two to four threes a game if I could go
to the free-throw line seven times I
mean I was trying to be efficient hmm
I'm not a jacker I wasn't a jacker only
in the playoffs are I Jack Moore so if
you look at my shadow Tim's playoffs
which is a regular season they always
went up in the playoffs because I
suppose that's when they needed you the
most that's why when you were a gunner
we had Patrick Ewing on yesterday got
his big win at Georgetown so I'm so
excited for the the big fella
a long time coming he should have been a
head coach at some level a long time ago
yeah he could have been out there
playing for UCLA
remember when Patrick said that he
wanted to go to UCLA I know could have
been it he could have been out there
wearing wearing the Bruins colors Ralph
drollinger and swim Nader but we were
talking about how intimidating
Georgetown was back then when you high
paranoia like that was a real deal yeah
and I mean Reggie Williams who was my
class teamed with the big fella and so
they had Michael Jackson I believe at
the time the point guard who had a full
court
yeah that was uh it was a real deal and
you could get away with a lot more back
and john thompson knew that the
Georgetown recruitment no they did not
I wasn't their kind of player no no why
not yeah you don't want to mess with
that
two to one as a team at Georgetown they
want you to pick up full court
one-on-one I like hold on
oh but if you got that big guy behind
you your defense gets a whole lot better
Reggie Aloysius Miller's got the Rockets
and the Suns
on Thursday night 10:30 Eastern on TNT
reg safe travels we'll talk to you next
week you're the best Theodore
thanks but for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]